If you're collaborating or
working on another computer,
the other party might not
have the linter configured.
Since your colleague needs to run
the build to work with the site anyway,
why not have the build run the linter,
and complain when something goes wrong?
Install the gulp-eslint package and
require it in the head
of your gulp file.
Turns out the basic example on the
gulp-eslint readme works well for us.
So I'm just going to copy it and
paste it into my gulp file.
[BLANK_AUIDO].
As you'll notice,
this task looks very familiar.
It has the gulp source code,
but this time fetches js files,
then uses pipes to do
a few things with eslint.
The first pipe executes eslint and
all files matched.
The second line outputs
the errors to the console, so
we actually see what happened.
And the third pipe ensures that gulp
exits with an error code and fails.
Without that line,
gulp would show the errors but
would proceed with everything else.
Now we could execute the task manually.
But let's integrate it
into our default task.
First, add it to the second
argument area after styles.
So it runs right after
running Gulp in the terminal.
Then add a new line after
gulp.watch to add a new Gulp watch.
This time watching the js files and
calling lint, instead of styles.
The best thing is that we can later
reuse this new watcher to do even more
great things to our js.
And there we go.
Try resetting Gulp in the terminal and
makes some changes through your js
to see linting appear on your
terminal after every save.
To wrap things up, there's a third
almost desperate way of forcing eslint
up on your project collaborators.
With a pre-commit hook,
you can let everyone go crazy
on your own file systems.
But as soon as they want to commit
a change to the shared git repository,
eslint will run error out and
not let a commit through.
In order to learn more
about pre-commit hooks,
you should check out our
source control Udacity course.